مشاهدينا في وقت تحاول السلطات الجورجيه
احتواء المظاهرات المتاججه في الشارع حولت
روسيا خط هذه الازمه باتجاه الغرب تخطيطا
وتنفيضا حيث اتهم رئيس اللجنه الدستوريه
في مجلس الاتحاد الروسي
كليش الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
بالقيامه بانقلاب غير دستوري في جورجيا
وشدد المسؤول الروسي على ان تغيير السلطه
في البلاد يجب ان يكون من خلال الانتخابات
وليس نتيجه الثورات دمويه تمولها الحكومات
الاجنبيه وفق تعبي
ره بدورها اعلنت احزاب المعارضه الجورجيه
انها ستواصل الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه كما
طالبت بالافراج عن عشرات المحتجين
المعتقلين من قبل القوات الامنيه
[موسيقى]
من جهته هي اعلن حزب الحلم الحاكم في
جورجيا سحب نواب البرلمان مشروع قانون
العملاء الاجانب المقترح بعد ايام من
الاحتجاجات المندده القانون الذي طرحته
الحكومه الجورجيه يحمل اسم شفافيه النفوذ
الاجنبي ويستهدف وسائل الاعلام والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه ويخشى منتقدون القانون من
استخدامه ذريعه من الحكومه لقمع المعارضه
اسوه بتشريع مماثل في روسيا
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات نحن بحاجه الى طرح هذا القانون على
الجلسه البرلمانيه المكتمله والغائه بشكل
رسمي